greetings everybody welcome to screen
Rockies universe where we'll be breaking
down Star Wars and giving you finally
our Star Wars spoiler review so if you
haven't seen the movie yet - now you
should have by now you've had plenty of
time this will be our spoiler centric
version I want to say this isn't an
honest trailer that's because we're
giving you this today we need a break
sometimes we can't do them all the time
we took one week off our apologies but
right now you're getting something super
special this guy was trending all
weekend over Star Wars and I wanted to
get his true feelings here listen to him
guys he has some smart thing to say and
he didn't hate the movie it made the
reboot innate the movie max landis
thanks for being here it's me the
Internet's most famous sexist of today
I've been compared this weekend to
donald trump and martin shkreli we're
not loving a movie welcome welcome
max very excited here what you send
trending all weekend mr. worldwide you
bullied me into doing I did I made him
come here guys I make that clear i he
was here shooting our special and I was
like working on Star Wars we gotta have
the man here who's been trending on his
feedback on Star Wars next to him Mr Dan
Morelle hi hey Dan I've also been
compared to Donald Trump and Martin
shkreli but for totally different
reasons and joining us the Star Wars
universe man himself mr. Ken nap sock
hey thanks for having it's gonna be fun
rolling up her sleeve and talking about
Star Wars in the nerd bubble let's do it
real quick this will be sorry we are
we're airing this now on YouTube it'll
be again on the screen eglise plus on
Wednesday where we typically do the show
live every week so if you're not a
member please check it out sorry Nicky's
calm but and we also have a TV fights
later tonight live if you watch I wanted
to get all that away so let's get right
into it those Star Wars so we sort of
know where you stand I want to come to
you first but let's get Dan and Ken what
are your thoughts now spoiler free we
can say everything's you know Han Solo
dies yeah we can say it all wow it feels
weird to finally be able to say that out
loud
go ahead I've seen it twice and my
second viewing I came up with pretty
much the same thing as my first viewing
was I enjoyed myself a lot I thought it
was a good movie with with some issues
you know it was a solid b-movie for me
not being movie but a solid b-movie and
yeah I certainly did it's not without
its problems but for me the good
overwhelm that can yeah for me I'm like
Dan at the beginning it was like it is a
movie with problems and I was a little
disappointed that the plot repeats and
to cover song a little bit of the
original three it's not just new hope
they take elements from all three the
movies and put them into one as I viewed
it more look-look at my hat look at my
life it's not a surprise that I crawl
into the Star Wars nerd bubble and can
really start digging into the myths that
they're putting out I think there's more
in this movie than other Star Wars
movies of Game of Thrones style myths
which is the style of making pop culture
properties right now is let's give you
something to climb into it so I'm buying
that I'm buying into that and I'm having
a lot of fun it's not though that I have
blind love like I saw a Phantom Menace
eight times in the theaters and only
eight times to realize I made a mistake
again I'm in the camp of both you Maxo
where do you stand this camp um trending
with hate no but I want you to get your
true feeling let's let's be clear no one
has asked me how I felt about the movies
yeah this is visit I thought it was okay
I thought it was like a sea it reminded
me too much of every other action movie
right now plus all the Star Wars stuff
and that disappointed me I thought the
characters are really thin a really thin
like I was shocked they were like video
game characters but then I thought the
villain was really fun I liked a lot of
the ideas of the plot like I loved the
Han and Leia stuff and and I liked the
ideas of every character I thought the
idea of Finn was great the idea of Rey
was great a lot of stuff well I guess
we'll get into it it was a movie that
for me it and I'm this is I didn't
Disney please don't kill me I didn't it
didn't have any of the edges of the
original Star Wars and by that I'm not
saying it's edgy but just starting one
thought why are there only Tie Fighters
and x-wings in this movie because
they're the Star Wars things Star Wars
fans yeah we're the b-wings I mean is
viewing in a b-wing be really cool in a
movie other than Jedi where the a wings
the B wings the Y wings where the tie
interceptors defending that giant base
where the time bombers where's the
tidies where's the tie advanced like you
I know the the universe got sent away
but all of the new things that were
introduced were just paint jobs of the
old things well let's let's talk about
the new things what did we like what
didn't we like I liked I liked Ray a lot
thought she was a fun character and I
relied I'd liked I do think there were a
little too many conveniences throughout
the movie of how we did that and
apparently the reason was the force but
I don't know I think we'll learn that in
the next movie but as of now I'm not
using that none of that hurt me enough
to dislike her and that brahmaiah the
new things are what won me over on this
movie is I agree that it I wish that
they had been a little more
inventiveness on for example the star
killer base I wish that there could have
been another I always a good have been a
more original set piece but the reason
that doesn't tank the movie is for me is
because I see that as exactly that it's
a set piece it's not like in a new hope
where the whole objective was to destroy
the Death Star and that was really all
that was going on I felt like that was
the backdrop for Rey and kylo ren's
final confrontation so I agree it could
have been a I wish it had been a little
more original but the new stuff is
wishes with a guy they've never met
before
I just want that is that true I mean my
head's already speculating if did they I
feel like han and Leia knew more about
Rey than they're telling us I agree I
agree with that but I don't think fans
speculation is is a good supposition for
like everyone was saying to me like like
ah you know ha everyone wants it both
ways with this movie cuz I said she's
too good at everything she hacks
everything she beats up everyone she
never struggles with anyone she gets
force frozen ones it's like a character
in a video game beating levels and I
just wanted her to struggle a little bit
so that I cared what happened to her I
knew she was going to be fine the whole
movie you know what I actually thought I
thought he was gonna say join me on the
dark side and she was gonna say yes and
it was gonna work the most badass film
twist ever anyone's and you woulda liked
it I wouldn't have liked it I would have
been better like oh it makes sense cuz
she's so tough why does she need this
baggage of Finn I don't what Scott and
you were caught this this was trending
worldwide you were calling her a Mary
Sue is what that means is a character
who gets learns adults Mary Sue is a
term created by a woman named Paula
something in a Star Trek magazine in the
in the 70s for a author insert and we've
all seen Mary Sue's like it's a
character who is too good at everything
never Master Chief from Halo
as a Mary Sue uh John McClane and like
the new diehards where he can blow up
anything is a Mary Sue and or they call
him Gary Stu's yeah but the reason it
was trending is because people thought I
was being like I was mad that there was
a female hero in Star Wars which is just
like I don't know to be clear that's all
it's hashtag mob war warfare not right
now you say one thing you're gonna be a
victim of just putting your opinion out
there and I think I get where you were
coming I mean even as a fan of what
Daisy really did with rain what they I
get what you're saying about formas
great performance and engaging and maybe
I think I from the beginning I love the
stuff on jakku with her just sitting
there being her and so I think I fell
into supporting the character then I but
some of your stuff to say and some of it
I think is just tentpole filmmaking
these days do you got a rush too much
the thing I also loved little thing like
the scene with the bread coming out of
the pan like yeah there were little
nuances like that practically don't
usually get to see them eat and do
things in the world where I do see like
I did give us a little more of the
layers but I don't disagree we could
have been had more I mean the biggest
disappointment for me was phasma we
actually been tweeting about this but
like they built up phasma they're like
oh my god we got Brienne of Tarth and
she did nothing and she just gave away
the shields like nothing and I guess
we'll learn more about her but I was
pitching I wish that scene where Finn
fights the the stormtrooper on the on
where were they in that world what role
was Adam yeah but what darker but yeah
yeah where as maz kanata's planetesimal
where that guy's a traitor that was a
cool sequence tree but I feel like the
Ottomans so much cooler if that was
phasma and we had given her at least a
scene to be a badass and not agree with
that by her but here's here's my larger
thing and I've been trying to write
something for screen Joker's calm kind
of in this vein is and the thing that's
kind of frustrating me a little bit is
like everyone here no one here thinks
it's a bad movie necessarily not not a
flattering or giving a passing grade I
in fascinate
I would never deserve it as a bad movie
when in a world where like really bad
right we're really bad movies in
transformers for exists yeah yeah what
I'm trying to figure out the most is is
why especially online the conversation
I've seen almost no conversation about
what's good about this movie it seems to
be almost exclusively what's bad even
from people that like it it seems almost
exclusively be like I didn't like
Captain phasma
I thought this was dumber I didn't like
this and I didn't like this and that's
what I'm trying to figure out is I I was
a
the opinion if you would have asked me a
week ago I would have said like man if
you say a bad thing about the force
awakens this weekend you are gonna get
pilloried but it's kind of the opposite
a lot of people that say good things
about this movie are when I certainly
was very positive
Max and I went back and forth a little
bit on Twitter this weekend but it's
surprising me that even people that like
the movie there seems to be a very big
focus on what was wrong with it and not
necessarily what was right with it so
I'm watching the hashtag sju live which
you can tweet in you're not watching
live where we put out the tweet for this
and there it's it's kind of split down
the middle even here Michael Kenny at
bridge of comps is have nothing to
declare apart from its brilliance but
then Yusuf kanessa says why have we
allowed a movie to reach this quote
untouchable pedestal so it's even now
well obviously this gives a history
there's so much baggage too we all have
something with Star Wars and I think
this is the first new one we all went in
I think most of us went in just sort of
like ah yes I think the kid in me
awakened as I've said just because I
shut off my critical brain at which we
do for a living but in that instance I
did fall for and then as I sat I think
we don't all notice those things it's
like well I wish they would have this
this this business but I agree for me as
an overall like I really enjoyed this
movie I think it's it's hard to keep
poking at it because it's like compared
to most movies at the level and the
expectations that this these people had
to make this movie I think they did a
pretty damn good job alright I have a
theory oh sorry no no go for it I was
just ask you a little bit more what is
your get talked about here and what
you're talking about um and it goes back
to what I keep saying about the movie is
that the movie didn't take enough big
swings to engender you know was the
great part there's no the great part in
this movie like when I think of New Hope
I mean like it's a good like it overall
is good but when I think of New Hope I
love when they're [ __ ] dressed up as
stormtroopers and they're like walking
chumma like I gotta mmm shoots the thing
and then Leia saves them cuz they get
trapped in that alway Lea's like into
the garbage chute and they go down there
in this movie oh god I don't wanna I
don't want to say like negatives but I
think I know exactly why people are
reacting this way
mm-hm and it's because there was no
point in this movie for a lot of people
not for everyone and if
you have a point where this happened for
you I'm not going to tell you you're
wrong but I think for a lot of people it
was a good movie but there was no Mad
Max do for your driving the thing there
was no specific moment and that left
people open to go like well they get
they run and they get shot at the bad
guys show up they run them they get shot
at the bad guys show up they run and
they get shot at I'll agree it is no
huge sequence I don't our small sequence
still to me is probably a better
sequence than any of this movie but I
think there were so many littler yes
individual er yeah nuanced moments in
this movie that they added up to feel
bigger as a whole
whereas phantom s only had that moment
which was amazing but it almost felt
like Elana Mundus the stood stunt team
should made that same inaudible the
podrace is well directed to it's just in
a boring terrible sure parable that's
actually interesting because the way
that I justified the prequels was that I
did remember those moments and I forgot
all the other stuff like you know even
as dumb as it kind of is now the Yoda
fight at the end of episode 2 at the
time you come out of that movie fresh
off having like yeah you know kicking
ass blah blah and then you see it again
II like oh [ __ ] I forgot about all the
sand and all this yeah the prequels for
all the negative things about them and I
would never compare the force awaken to
the prequels because no one it's just a
better movie and number two its problems
are entirely different the prequels have
so many new and crazy and interesting
ideas in them worlds and characters and
vehicles yet and and so like the
prequels even though there's like a city
on water in a city in the clouds and
there's all these parallels there Jango
Fett and Boba Fett guess what Jango Fett
in his execution was a very different
character than Boba Fett Anakin sucks
he's one of the worst protagonists in
film history but you can name the
reasons he sucks hmm
rey is spunky she's tough she you know
like Anakin's a worse character than her
but you can say more about him right now
I can I I found myself tonight with her
when she was uh it's very brief it's a
brief moment when she's sitting there
when she's cleaning that when she's
cleaning the the things she scavenged
she looks across it she sees the old
woman and it's not a big moment but you
can see in that interplay the kind of
conflict that's within her
think that they did a lot of character
development with her I you know I agree
yeah she can do a bunch of stuff but
Luke Skywalker you do a bunch no we
couldn't
he could everyone can make a desktop
that's one thing he did
and if plan despite a thing that he
never flown before he goes on the city
trench okay so here's the Skywalker's
character he's introduced yeah we spend
an hour with him yeah his life sucks
he's a whiny dick okay he wants to be a
pilot he's apparently good at piloting
that said a bunch of times do you
remember when Luke says I'll just fly
them all just young pilot myself I'm not
such it's established again and again
and again it's also established that
there's a thing called the force that
lets people do cool stuff right nobody
wanted us to use the fools yeah it's his
ghost and you remember when Luke has a
lightsaber and he's getting shot by a
toy or when he has to get saved by
Princess Leia how do we be honest oh
he's a beast so whiny
I'm not sure you watch it but so is
Anakin and now so is going at some of
the parts it's a family line it's a
family trail so as far
I'm not saying Luke's a perfect hero
he's just not right Mary Sue I get what
you know absolutely ray kind of fun
comes fully formed which now we're
putting a lot into it but how much of
this max especially your take on the
industry is like I said the tentpole
filmmaking that they have to kind of
rush those this is a summer blockbuster
released at December Lucas is an auteur
who created his own world and had his
own pace in and could put some of the
stuff in that he did so well I don't
want to compare but it is a different
time don't you think they did a great
job in what they had you know you know
what I liked in a summer blockbuster
that had more action than this but who
are related to more hmm woman called
furiosa fair enough
I understood what was going on with her
I was invested in her terrible story
though it's a nothing story but you like
the characters so much in the action so
Wanda come here here's why I'm gonna
reserve judgment on Ray is I feel like
there's a lot that we've yet to learn
because is that fair though shoot a
movie coming out give you that feeling
now or she'll be like okay because we
don't give that that same regard to
Twilight or Harry Potter or all these
part one that's fair this is our base
doesn't some just to be fair like are
they because I agree with you man that
I'm also struggling like is that fair
for that's I'm not saying they didn't
leave themselves open up to criticism if
this is the case I'm not saying it
wasn't
a really good decision but the reason
that I'm holding judgment back on that
because watching it the first time I did
kind of feel like wow how does she know
all that I'm gonna I'm gonna reserve
judgment because I feel like we may
learn that she is perhaps more powerful
than maybe any Jedi that we met yet it
is called the force awakens and I feel
like we could learn some things that
kind of explain that again I'm not
saying that's necessarily a great
decision to leave yourself open to that
kind of criticism but I'm not gonna jump
on that train just yet maybe after
episode 8 I can go yeah they were kind
of played fast and loose I have a side
note which is that I don't think she was
the only thin character I think people
jumped all over me because they didn't
notice that I also had things to say
about Poe Dameron a badass mm-hmm and
that's it that's it and him and Finn a
clumsy cowardly bumbler and that's it we
don't even know why he turned I mean we
can say it was the force but what he got
his helmet got too bloody like he's in
his first battle again there's yes whoa
there Hitler Youth yeah there Hitler you
yeah but I would hope and assume he's
heads well she did say this is the first
transition but yeah there must have been
I would it would have been nice to see
some other moments but what if how do
you fit it all in right what you're not
in there easily cut out the dumb
chemical monsters on hands well that I
definitely know the rathtar sir that was
the only one that liked it it's two men
in black 2 for me it was a little weird
for me and just something all got out
and just all the bad guys got eaten one
scene where was at the opening movie is
the raveling and FN is like is like like
that and you see that his gun shaking in
his hand and you don't see his face you
don't know it's boyega and the
stormtrooper next to him goes first time
out stick with me I'll protect you and
he goes okay I'm like uh I don't know
you know I'm supposed to be back up on
the ship captain phasma goes why quiet
both of you
and he goes just stay with me they go
down to the planet that guy gets shot
blood on the helmet oh it's easy
look it's only it takes time I would
love a max landis stroke offering on
star right
incoming better I'm not I do like that
Moselle I'm not saying I would never say
that I just everything I say is just fan
diction of a movie is it was the Han
Solo death I'm as biggest fan as I was I
didn't cry or a baby from it wasn't cry
either as they had they had they they
scratch a lot he does he they squished
in a lot to that moment it was like we
had to learn like if he if they have
thought Ren was dead and or their son
was dead and and on and that moment
learns oh my god he's alive and he's
this guy and now he's gonna kill me that
might have had a little more weight to
me in the moment I felt we had a kind of
a lot of exposition on but I gotta give
I think Harrison Ford did a pretty good
performance giving way had an amazing I
agree with you giving away it I think
had a lot but there you could see a lot
in his face as he was trying to give you
as much as he could and the time he was
allowing back to give Han a proper
Viking funeral he was really the whole
you thought about the music he was good
the whole moon was then he's been in
years like yeah even gets into him a
Supporting Actor nominee like later in
some of these awards like he really I
think brought a new layer to him and had
some depth I totally agree that's my
tibia squall as the movie were r2d2
waking up for no reason which they did
not properly explain now and I did feel
like the death of Han Solo I felt like
the story reasons were there but I felt
like it was treated as just another
event in the movie and then it was
quickly moved on and and I would they
needed to give that I felt a moment it
needed a it parallels the death of
obi-wan wearing two characters are far
away and ready it but if you really
wanted to like punchy in the stomach
with it it should have been phasma
easily overpowered and captures them and
then is like I'm taking them to kill
them and then Ren who we think killed so
we just like you said we set it up like
cat phasma overpowers them and then Ren
goes no I think it's important that I
talk to mr. solo you know home yeah that
is like his life does it bother you that
I killed your son
and it's like laughing at him and the
audience is like damn this guy's a
psycho that said I am your son 80s I
like that that's also good Ren proven
you did play him right yeah
that's correct and then I dyed my hair
yeah but what a so let's talk Luke yeah
but what are the feelings on Luke cuz my
that was one thing that frustrated me is
like I like I'd like seeing him but I
wish they hadn't put them all over the
poster and teased he's in the movie he
would be on the poster he's teasing
Simon I'm billing on the poster so my
frustration was like why couldn't they
have just made it like was he alive
we don't know if he's alive rumored he's
been dead if you're going to give us
that sort of little tease at the end I
wish they could have used as a bigger
surprise or and just not told anybody
like he's not in the movie he's gone and
then was there or just don't give it to
us give him a proper reveal later in the
second movie rather than this weird
tease at the end of the first one which
to me does feel like wait there's more
stick around our story's not over I I
like I like like I thought I said on our
screen checking show I think it's a
brave choice do it now I regret that
there's not one more han and Luke
together again how we doing same as
always that bad like I would have liked
that kind of moment with Hamlin Ford
regret we're not gonna get that but I
like that I like it man in this day and
age of leaving things in the end and
connecting stories together to me was
more like it was a build up of like oh
he's gonna be here is gonna be here and
then there he gives me a face and we're
over I think they were in a no-win
scenario with the movie which is that
there was no way in today's culture that
they were gonna be able to keep it a
secret that he was in the movie the
moment the photos I'm an amalgam photo
was immediately leaked six months ago
wha
so I think they had a choice to do JJ
already did the thing of the whole with
Khan just denying that so no it's not
Khan and then Khan's like oh [ __ ] you
sorry screw you for tell me that Khan's
not the movie when he is and I think
they had to be like either we say he's
not in it and it's a huge distraction
because everyone obviously knows he is
or we say he is in it and everything to
be pissed off because he's only in the
end of the movie I liked it what did you
like it max can I tell you something
really weird that resonates of
everything okay so this is gonna be
really weird I'm a FEMINIST and I was
very going into this movie super excited
because I think women women are
basically the same as men but also women
tend to look cooler if I'm being honest
when they do guy stuff like like they
look cool and when I was seeing images
of Ray I thought she looks cool
the image to me in my head in the end of
the movie I kind of left the movie like
cool because it was a female Luke
Skywalker ray with Chewbacca and r2d2
yeah and the Millennium Falcon and
obi-wan Kenobi Luke and I went oh that's
such a great image like I got very moved
and I was like yeah and that I thought
about ray and I got bummed out but like
but like for a minute there it totally
sold me I was like that images algid
tricking you all it was the image of
life there was an image - Daisy's such a
good actress and very small busy my old
friend Daisy Daisy Daisy Ridley's such a
good actress and she's small her
standing next to Chewbacca is so
cool-looking and like it just feels like
Star Wars and I got very excited sorry
this is something I like some of my
favorite moments a movie when they're
flying before they get there yeah he's
really good that she looks at Chewie
there's a great one where shoo he's kind
of like yeah it's yours now and she's
the captain of winning Falcon yeah I
love it and I think that she did some
great it was like it dawned on her at
the same time - as it dawned on the
audience like she's got it now and I
like that a lot and that's what party
are the reason I really like the end so
where do we think it's going with
thoughts feelings I mean I assume we're
all excited to see the next one
that's good question can I ask you a
question yes okay so maybe I'm stupid
in fact I'm definitely scared but but
can I ask you said it but can I ask a
question which is okay so if you have a
map of the galaxy this has been stuck in
my you've seen up four times four times
why didn't I know where it was with the
piece they had well okay so I asked that
first but it made sense in the second
time okay so let me set up the question
in that if it makes sense answer so if
you have a map of the galaxy and you
have one piece of it that shows a whole
little section of a solar system and the
sole assist and the piece you have says
there is where Luke is okay and then you
have another piece of the map that is
giant and in r2d2 who's in low-power
mode
I guess for rest mode he's in a he's in
uh he's gone to plot device uh for a
while uh wouldn't you technic
only need the portion of the map you
have or the line on the map that shows
Luke Luke's trajectory wouldn't all the
explained it did think yes a second I'm
sorry I figure I'll throw a line is it's
too expansive to know where and the map
it is is what they said on the piece is
too hard too hard to decipher we're in
the grander scheme of where they need to
go if I had the same problem when I say
at least ya tried to throw what is a
throwaway like it's totally weird it's
time for your question but just go no no
don't worry about it it's a place we
didn't know I said they did attempt just
like they also said Han Solo's like well
you think we had a tracker like we did
cuz I was like how did they find the
Falcon oh yeah skater yeah but they did
throw a line of like well if we can find
them our scanner they can - I still
don't know why r2d2 woke up and one of
thousand others voice course it's a
pretty - the presence of rain Mike but
didn't no one else want Luke to show up
in that battle at the end like is when
the I'm glad she had the moment that is
what I like it as a brave choice it
would have been achieved applause I just
want to say something I did want him to
show up on top of that I the biggest
beef for me in this movie like if I
could only choose one thing and I loved
everything else let's say that the thing
I would choose is why is everybody great
with a lightsaber why is the villain of
the movie understand that Wren is weak
and he's gray and he's not strong with
the dark side of the force
why the [ __ ] is he getting not just not
just beaten but his ass whooped in this
movie can I swap can I can I cut in half
can I fight back against that because a
movie fight I watched I watched I
watched the second time with a very
careful eye toward that because I
flagged a little bit the first time I
watched it he's in shock he there's
lotsa reason he's injured he's
emotionally conflicted oh I think he's a
total fraud which is which is kind of
what was raised I was like yeah you're a
total poser but I was watching them
especially the Finn fights like well
friends only you know not even a Jedi I
was watching I watched that very
carefully and and and kylos almost
toying with him Finn is running and Rey
up at so she has her force moment is
also running from him and he is she
poked him guys help you me not it's a
lot of just look it's like what I got me
de monterrey has your first force moment
which you can go with or you cannot but
but I think that some people are
remembering it a little different you
misunderstand my question yeah and this
happened to me when I talked about the
city destruction at the end of Man of
Steel - this happens to me a lot because
I talk about stories from the
perspective of a writer right it's not
how did he get hurt I know how he got
hurt he'd been shot with a bow caster he
was emotionally conflicted and he then
was but he really isn't toying he
should've just been able to kill finanza
but regardless you're talking about
things that happen in the movie I'm
talking about
story-wise stakes wise he's the villain
he just killed Han Solo he just killed
Han Solo let him kick some ass now
instead of being a pretty fair fight
with the leads let him get but so you
think he should I don't know I disagree
I think he should be conflicting the
head because I think he was a little was
torn and killed I think he believed what
he said of I can't do this without you
moment he just killed his father who his
people I think probably has some light
at him right but look it up what is the
threat of a villain who can be beaten by
two people at the end of the first movie
well see that and that's my thing it's
not about the choice it's about he
should have been obviously toying with
them instead of well if you watch it
real close I did love that see mine my
disgrace is cool where I differ and I
see a lot of people saying that it's
just like oh he was a weak he was a weak
villain he was a weak Darth Vader and
for me that's that's what I loved about
his character was that Star Wars has
this problem and they keep doing it as
I've done in all six movies even Darth
Vader in the first one you don't learn a
lot about him until a second one that's
when he becomes evil the first one he's
a henchman in a black suit yeah and and
what they do with villains and Star Wars
is they produce a fully-formed villain
who's an evil guy and that's pretty much
it Darth Maul cool looking good with the
lightsaber disposable Count Dooku
Christopher Lee voice again evil and
what I liked about kylo Ren is that he
was a villain who wasn't fully formed
and he was capable of getting his ass
kicked probably when he should have
dominated it and I think that's where
I'm now interested I was never really
interested in the characters of any of
the villains in the Star Wars movies
before
I'm interested in his character
specifically because like how does he
deal with that how do you deal with the
fact that yeah he got his ass kicked by
these two people that he should not have
gotten beaten by is he gonna come back
stronger is he gonna keep fighting
against the light I think that's why I
push back against that a little bit but
you know again it's it's it's all a case
of like yes the screenplay does take
short cuts and I think maybe they do
obscure some things that they could have
saved them so some grief on if they
establish little more problems yeah but
like PS fin is established as a janitor
and yet he's able to use a lightsaber
efficiently enough to fight a trains not
only that amazing I've only used a
blaster in any shooting I think the
ships really well and several different
space ships it's just all video game
[ __ ] they are as capable as they might
to be I don't disagree I also didn't
care I feel like I'm I feel I think
that's reason I think I'd say usually I
do care cuz that we have Morimoto I want
to see max agrees as Finn his buddy dies
blood on his thing and he's conflicted
and then to escape he destroys all the
other people he probably was in an
academy with with a gun none of it makes
sense
I mean if Escape was where I'm gonna
save you how did you know who he was by
full Cameron just being like how much
Betty get to the TIE fighter he's the
best Thai fighter fighter I did love Poe
only cuz that opening shower is like am
I supposed to talk are you supposed to
blow this that was a great I thought
that set up an amazing thing but then we
never leave to see more of it you have
just hit on my biggest weird thing about
the movie and again I don't hate it
all of those Whedon things it was we've
got a boyfriend you got a cute boyfriend
that was not a place of writing please
Troy please all three places with me no
no but all all of those is not the way
people talk in a Star Wars movie which
this is a new store movie universe
except everyone else the rest of the
time yeah acts and talks like they're in
Star Wars so when they do that it's like
iron that was the first moment in the
movie cuz it's a great line yeah who's
gonna talk first you were me but it was
like what what I think it worked coming
out of him and I don't disagree that
would probably some other moments ie
that I like that moment there's other
moments yeah yeah listen I it's it's I
guess it was it was an out all this
movie was going to be subject to micro
analysis I mean that song about we Lions
do yeah I didn't know we liked uh well
here's what I'll say overall in general
Star Wars is I think that it was almost
an impossible task because JJ had to
please
this was the bridge movie so JJ had to
please the people that love the old
movies that don't want anything to
change ever and the people who don't
care about the old man just people who
love the prequel if people love the
prequels and they and believe me there's
a generation we come out with the our
children Jason don't remind me it's a
full generation who love the prequels
and the people that just want to see
something new and somehow he had to
please oh and a simple language and on
the Star War like there's a lot of party
three weeks ago I got over there making
another one is Jan J directed the first
one the Star Trek exactly so we got to
secret this hundred percent dan I've
given all that I've given all that I
think yes there's a flaws but but for
him to pull it off well enough that I
came out of it excited about the future
and now for me episode eight is where my
analysis and my pressure is gonna be is
like okay you had a bridge movie I think
you did a great job
you fell into some potholes but I M so
data's for me is gonna be okay what's
this new trilogy have to offer me well
let's go and then finally I said I liked
Leia I was surprised I liked the moments
we had our thought she was strong and it
was a little worried about seeing older
Carrie Fisher cuz she is slightly crazy
sometimes but I thought she got right in
there and was amazing and I thought the
saga bring her back I wish we'd gotten
some more moments with it but in those
small moments we had I thought her and
um Harrison Ford I think did great
honestly uh is our final wrap-up yeah
what if it was something you liked uh I
liked a lot of yeah like a moment you
did like I liked a lot of it I loved uh
the kylo Ren in a different with a
different set up to it I really enjoyed
kylo ren's confrontation with Ray in the
room where she goes take off the mat I
you're a dummy in a mask and he goes
[ __ ] you Here I am and she goes oh and
then he tries to do the mind thing and
she goes you're scared yeah although it
doesn't make any sense because Anakin
would have reached out to him by now and
said the darkside is a dad if you had an
owner go million people ghost ghosts if
he was like Bo Theo if he was like Darth
Vader hey yellow force freeze the force
slept men how [ __ ] scary would it be
if if when the big hologram of snow
comes up it's [ __ ] Darth Vader
because no one knows
Vader was Anakin no one knows that Ezra
and so it says Vader and he son could be
lord Vader
that would have been like how many the
king came buddy something I loved yes
something I loved the first order I
thought they were scary I thought the
way domhnall gleeson played his
character was really scary I thought
everything about them said the stuff
that I liked in the first Star Wars
movies about the Empire's which are
these are fascists I really I really
just love the idea of Rey and Finn I
love the idea of a good storm trooper
and of this girl from the desert who
maybe has some mythic connection to the
story I love the execution of kylo Ren
the actors put the the performance I
thought Leia should have died I thought
Ren shoulda got Han and Leia ma why go
really dark hair yeah and and give him
something so that when he gets beaten
the [ __ ] out of in a couple seconds
later you're like yeah [ __ ] about
however I love bb-8 like this even
what's like little cat purring it was
cute he's a fun new art you you favorite
thing in the movie it's me c-3po
you probably don't recognize me the red
arm I'm it's that amazing moment I loved
it uh g3p oh yeah my fav my favorite
thing by far was Han Solo and Harrison
Ford's performance that just the fact
that it was hunts it wasn't here some
Ford and Han Solo clothes
it was Han Solo and he was back and I
love that I love Poe and Finn's dynamic
and I look forward to seeing more of it
in the second movie and them actually
exploring they seem like a really fun
pair together cute they're really cute
kind of pair and I and I look forward to
that
I love Dre's character I'm looking
forward to her and Luke Skywalker doing
the Jedi training thing and I think it's
gonna be a different Luke Skywalker he's
gonna probably be a little more
depressed and a little more wary and a
little more skeptical for me for me what
ultimately won me over on this movie and
what may if depending on Upstate sink it
is the promise I think it's set up so
many promising things for the future and
that's what sold me more than anything
else and you know again the stories yet
to be written at the end of this we may
say oh boy how wrong how wrong was I but
right now it got me excited about the
future Star Wars again which is
something I haven't felt in a very very
very long time
ken but for me it really really adds
some layers to the new Canon which
they're doing so much trying to rebuild
not all of it perfect so far but some of
its really great Reed lost stars by
Claudia gray to meet some of the themes
this movie it was about a mythical type
of these characters trying to accept or
not accept their roles and I like the
switch of a villain who he instead of
trying to you know avoid going to the
dark side he's trying to avoid to go
going to the light side which is a
different switch for me I loved Ray more
than you though I can acknowledge that
I'm in the Star Wars nerd bubble look
I'm an adult male Star Wars stickers on
my computer so I get it I get it man but
I liked and just the feeling of it and
hey they got some of the that they got
the original truly wrapped up into one
movie so now Rian Johnson can take it
into a new territory and I hope that I
agree that you shouldn't base of your
judgment on a movie and what could also
come with it but that's also the time
because you look something happen to
Game of Thrones you don't like don't
worry it's attached to something else
and will make sense later that's just
kind of where we are when it comes to
some of this is a pop culture filmmaking
well the crazy thing I when Kevin Smith
was on he was saying they're all
prequels now and it's kind of it's true
we have to call them off I refuse to do
technically it's so it's so hard
frequent refer to one specific set of
movies it's funny
can I ask can I ask a final question
sure of you guys yes question absolutely
so they got rid of the expanded universe
yes
but they didn't really need it that
doesn't mean it doesn't exist who is the
character from the expanded universe who
you would be most excited or surprised
to see show up because there's there's
Han and Leia's son going to the darkside
I mean like they're they're elements of
the expanded universe in this movie no
Jason for me um I think if if what we're
led to believe that Rey is related to
Luke give me a Mara Jade type character
I'd love that I am I will like I will
put my cards on the table I am
completely ignorant of the the former
expanded universe I I rather say Jackson
the rope the rabbit x-wing pilot I read
a few I read a few books the ones that
had the Millennium Falcon on it because
Han Solo was my favorite character there
was one that crashed on the planet but I
never actually really got an expanded
universe yeah I'm with him
either one you're looking forward to
seeing I mean they're two they're
they're three and I'm being honest the
three best uh
Mar Jade Luke's partially Sethe troubled
really intense cool smart wife and
mother to his children uh Grand Admiral
Thrawn the only alien ever to serve in
the empire yes
who has blue white skin and is
incredibly vicious and is just one of
the great villains and one of the great
character designs absolutely and I
really want Leia to be like hey Finn Poe
you guys need to go pick up Luke we need
a pilot who do you know well I know one
guy but he's pretty old now - Rand are
ya shadows of the end shadows of the
[ __ ] Empire he's not dead
that was the UM can I stay believe a lot
of people happy yeah a lot of people
happy Mara Jade would make me just some
persons awesome I dunno about her yeah
that would be a fun I don't think
they're gonna do it though I think
they're creating their own cannon now
they are but but no reason they couldn't
steal and I suppose pull it out of your
pocket and yeah be like oh it's her yeah
kilt they don't they're there they're
definitely nudging and making some nods
to the okay the Sun crusher type of
thing was a little bit of tie-in to this
planet the star killer base and then
Jason hello I did not do another base no
well you know the Sun crusher was people
loved it made it yeah I yeah it's a way
it's a big ship the destroyed little and
little [ __ ] to the sighs next one yeah
the destroys Suns instead there's this
amazing thing in the expanded universe
where they designed this little ship
that looks like a funnel that can blow
up sons and they're like we need the
best pilot and then a basically the Star
Wars version of a school shooter a kid
who's like losing his mind to the
darkside
steals it and the whole book is like oh
no it's such a good I really like it
some people hate it yeah but I think was
a nod and it was a little bit of nod to
some of them yeah uh well awesome I this
was a very fun conversation thank you
for coming I know we're planning a movie
fight with you sometime a new year if
you're willing to come back yes as long
as I don't have to give my opinions on
modern news yeah but uh thank you for
doing this and I you clearly know your
stuff Star Wars night I appreciate the
the intelligent conversations thanks for
coming max and she'd go by American
alien writing in comic book stores now
American ale
in issue 3 comes out next month but
issues 1 & 2 it's my revamp D Mary suing
of Superman uh not a reason that Mary
Superman because he is in some ways most
Superman he's a tech but yeah please
check it out yeah yeah please do dan
Moreau Merle Dan anything you'd like to
plug good sir no I can I just say after
after an entire weekend of on Twitter it
was nice to have this lovely
conversation we could share our
differences and and yet still be nice to
each other yeah
this is very nice i I said it this
weekend whether you like the movie you
didn't like the movie people online or
pissed at you about that well I called
the mails if they don't like the movies
I was told by someone that I was a
sexist he should get syphilis cannot
pack anything i TV fights live tonight
right and every tuesday Angela tonight
with Jason Mewes Rob C from Survivor and
Dan Morel stepping into the TV fights
realm yeah a lot of fun man I love that
we're talking about Star Wars again and
hey man aren't they on the Internet
common sense doesn't rain but it's nice
to have max coming here and kind of
explain himself a little bit I think I
think you love being a lightning rod
sometimes and it's fun to watch you spin
but I also know you're very intelligent
opinions on how are you nice people and
I enjoy joint discussion with you thank
you can I had fun too
I thank you guys for watching again no
Astro today but TB fights live at four
if you're watching today only and we
will have a screen junkies extended
holiday special special Christmas
special featuring max Lane isn't very
Will Ferrell Mark Wahlberg
Doug Benson was really happy Lulla
you'll want to tune in it's dropping on
screen no keys plus the extended version
we also utilize Wednesday and then a
smaller cut down on screen ducky show on
Thursday so thank you guys so much for
watching
screener keys accom see you next time
you